so where are we right now don't know
yeah you're supposed to say semis
yes what are we doing now yes
fried alligator tail so that what is
going on look how much candy
how many heaven okay
cinnamon gummy bear
so we're here on holiday we've booked
this trip ages ago tomorrow we're going
to meet up with Marcia's friend and just
check out the city is that right such as
Bryan it looks very pretty
we found a famous landmark
it was closed here's the real reason why
we're in Savannah might say I have
something to tell you I ate all the
candy
yeah not done yeah it did what are you
doing no health care walking or moving
a mobar holy Sh a look at this ice-cream
line that's got to be good ice cream
wait tell me how to live my life
wait how does that thing float that is
so big
just felt like it was time to get a real
tattoo on my foot has anyone ever gotten
that one before really it's popular
we have too much hair on my foot is it a
problem alright so here that's good for
you I love it down you want to go down a
little bit but every more little bit
more and a little bit to your right
would be right there
yeah
a what
good
it's too cold yeah you touch it how do
you like that my foot tattoos but in the
year four tattoo whoa whoa whoa boy that
is really cool
I'm not Swedish anymore so remember that
ice cream store I was making fun of
we're going there because we read
reviews that it's the best ice cream
ever so obviously we gotta go and now I
gotta wing look at that loser she's such
a loser
I can't even embarrassing we're walking
and I saw this oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god go okay that's
pretty that's pretty freaking hardcore
man there's like freaking lights and
everything look at all those nerds we're
gonna be the same nerds in a second
it's pretty good
my name's Wayne Mathers why you do this
well isn't this romantic
don't touch my boob okay this is the end
of today's vlog I beat the final level
yeah so anyway awesome game
we're here with I don't know where we're
gonna all right guys okay we're good
hard just don't leave also velocity they
get to that National Lab parking a
closet torture that was the most intense
chore on my on my life back that was
crazy
let's sit there that's where that fella
Tom Hanks sat on a bench in pretended to
be me you know that bench is not there
anymore
so this is stop number five that was a
lot longer than I thought we didn't even
go to the park tomorrow tomorrow we're
going to the park
where are we going almost time
here's marks yet I mean mafia idea how
much longer
we had amazing pizza now we're going to
that ice cream place for this super long
line
we're back in the amazing line it's
worth it is really good
oh my god Tom Cruise had an ice cream
here was this the greatest day of my
life my god
inception guy he's always eating the ice
cream oh my god his Miley Cyrus I don't
know what happened I asked for a waffle
create a pie eat stuff the blog this is
great stuff all right
we had our ice cream we had our pizza
what a day right
right god we're playing the best game
ever quickest hey it's all pretty
consistent though so we're playing this
game at amazingphil okay might win and
there's a pretty good
boring there's supposed to be a
leprechaun but I thought it was a flower
- part 1 I tried to make this dog shine
look that's awesome good night bye
better than that
bad bad a pap good night today was
really fun another day tomorrow see you
then oh Sh
oops Planet fun is right here 1 hearse -
hurts which hurts are hurt I don't
believe it
we found a real ghost they will they
will attest